[Música]
Hola bienvenidos al debate de France 24
soy Santiago López González el
secretario de estado de asuntos europeos
de Francia Clemente Junior fue enfático
en cuanto a las vacunas que su país
Zavala con miras a impulsar en ese
momento un ambicioso plan de
inmunización nacional el funcionario
afirmó que solo las vacunas autorizadas
por la agencia europea del medicamento
serán reconocidas por el pase sanitario
de su país según el sitio oficial de la
Ema que es la european Medical agency
Estas son las vacunas avaladas dentro
del grupo de los 30 países de la Unión
Europea estamos hablando de los 27
estados miembros más Islandia Noruega y
lichtenstein les muestro a continuación
las vacunas producidas por los
laboratorios de pfizer Byron Johnson y
Johnson moderna y astracénica pero
excluyen la versión de astracénica que
es fabricada en la India Estas son las
que son avaladas en Europa el secretario
también añadió lo está descartado que
quien viaje a Francia con una vacuna de
cuya protección no estamos seguros esto
haciendo referencia por supuesto a la
vacuna rusa spot que tiene pues no tiene
autorización para ser usada en este país
Aunque la Ema tiene cinco vacunas más
que están en estudio es decir está
mirando la posibilidad de avalarlas para
ser usadas en su territorio tenemos por
ejemplo la de laboratorio chino sinovac
que comenzó a ser estudiada el pasado 4
de mayo mientras que la vacuna rusa de
la cual les estaba hablando las comenzó
a ser estudiada incluso mucho antes el 4
de marzo la medida ha dejado a miles de
ciudadanos franceses que viven en el
extranjero sin la posibilidad de
regresar a su país de origen porque en
el lugar de residencia han sido
inoculados con alguna de estas dos
vacunas o una china o la vacuna rusa les
tenemos algunos testimonios de
ciudadanos franceses que tienen este
problema escuchemos
pues no tengo intención de viajar pronto
a Francia pero tengo familia allá Uno
nunca sabe cuando va a tener que viajar
como Con urgencia y el problema es que
el gobierno francés no reconoce ni la
rusa ni la China y sin embargo tampoco
deja alternativas me da mucho que pensar
en los intereses económicos y políticos
que pueda tener que puedan tener los
diferentes países de la Unión Europea
porque como por casualidad la que las
que no reconocen es precisamente la rusa
y la china
aparte encuentro esto un poquito
discriminatorio en el sentido de que
pues al venir a Colombia
como bien saben tenemos que ponernos
ponernos diferentes vacunas entre ellas
la Fiebre amarilla a mí me tocó una zona
de Selva entonces la rabia y todo eso en
ningún momento ha habido problemas
de reconocimiento de esas personas que
le acabo de mencionar con una marca o
por otra entonces por qué Por la del
coronavirus para la vacuna del
coronavirus hay tantos problemas
Yo hace dos meses soy padre de un niño
que nació y y pues mis habíamos planeado
que mi suegra venga acá en Francia para
para ver al niño para para cuidar al
niño y ella está vacunada con con
sinovac y resulta que si no va no está
reconocido por Francia y pues para mí si
está reconocida por la MS Sería bueno
que el acuerdo será internacional o sea
por qué Por qué Francia lo refusa y Eso
no lo entiendo bien No lo entiendo bien
Estoy un poco triste y sobre todo no veo
como pues ella está bloqueada totalmente
bloqueada así se Entonces eso me parece
Injusto me
de mayo yo hizo la sinovac
la vacuna sinovaca en mes de junio la
segunda
sinovac y el día de hoy yo no puede
salir a Francia sí hace pocas cosas Ayer
en la vista porque a nivel mundial
y sí estamos todo preocupado porque
hemos tenido antes de todas partes del
mundo a día de hoy tenemos muy millón
800 mil franceses al exterior
estamos ocupados que muchos países
actualmente he podido suministrar el
sputnik la buisia o la sinovac la
Organización Mundial de la Salud la OMS
instó a los países a reconocer todas las
vacunas que ellos han autorizado
incluidas las que son fabricadas en
China o en Rusia de lo contrario los
países podrían estar socavando la
confianza en las vacunas así lo han
dicho textualmente Qué puede hacer
Entonces el gobierno francés que puede
hacer la Unión Europea que pueden hacer
para hacer frente a esta situación de
estos miles de personas que viven o de
franceses que viven alrededor del mundo
que no pueden regresar a su país de
origen cómo equilibrar los derechos de
los ciudadanos para quienes deben
regresar a su país de origen y la
bioseguridad en medio de la pandemia de
19 algunos países como Alemania Bélgica
Suiza incluso España avalan diferentes
vacunas pero se ciñen a la normativa de
la Ema a la hora de inocular a sus
ciudadanos es decir ellos reciben a
personas que quieran visitar el país y
que tengan vacunas ya inoculadas
procedentes de Rusia o de china porque
son personas que van a estar allí por un
tiempo determinado entonces pues ya
tenemos el tema tenemos a los invitados
tenemos el contexto damos inicio
Entonces al debate de France 24 y para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
Felipe volant analista político
Internacional del partido a la República
en marcha en la ciudad de Bogotá él es
uno de los representantes también está
con nosotros
Xavier Sáenz llorens él es jefe de
infectología y director investigación
clínica del hospital del niño en Ciudad
de Panamá también es investigador
internacional en vacunas en el centro
sebaxin también allí en Panamá y también
desde la redacción de francés de 24 está
con nosotros en Nicolás guillot en los
ciudadano francés el estaba vacunado con
la vacuna de sinovac que es desarrollada
en China y Nicolás es colaborador de
France 24 en español
aclaramos que la redacción y la
producción del programa intentó tener
para este programa a alguien que
representara al gobierno francés para
tener una postura oficial sobre este
tema Pero todas las solicitudes que
hicieron fueron rechazadas y rechazaron
esta invitación de asistir al programa
para dar su punto de vista ustedes
también en nuestros televidentes son
parte de esta conversación a través de
redes sociales ustedes pueden dejar
comentarios y preguntas en nuestra
cuenta en Facebook también en Instagram
y en Twitter
estamos como arroba France 24_es mi
cuenta personal@santilogo dejen todos
los comentarios con el numeral el debate
f24 pues comienzo entonces preguntándole
a Felipe sobre esta situación sobre su
impresión sobre este panorama de los
miles millones de franceses que están
alrededor del mundo sin poder regresar a
su país de origen por tener una vacuna
rusa o una vacuna China o porque
simplemente no ha podido acceder a una
vacuna por ser extranjeros bueno primero
hay que decir que las embajadas está
haciendo un trabajo fenomenal se puede
vacunar pero el problema es que las
embajadas están dando la vacuna de
Johnson Y si miramos justamente los
textos Usted dijo que podían ingresar
pero para la jota de Johnson uno que
tiene que esperar cuatro semanas
de ser vacunado para poder ingresar el
país entonces aquí ya veo un poquito un
problema de logística dado que las otras
son siete días después podemos ver que
en los países por ejemplo fue el caso de
mi esposa Yo tuve la ventaja de tener
las vacunas mencionadas autorizadas Ella
tenía la sinovac entonces tuvo que
buscar varios puntos para encontrar un
lugar donde ir apoyando de vacunar con
la una de las aceptadas porque sabíamos
desde hace meses que eso iba a tardar y
que la agencia Europea de medicamentos
había dado dicho que justamente estas
vacunas no eran autorizadas en Europa y
Francia se atrapó a esta ley de la
agencia europea del medicamento para
justamente cuidarse en salud de este
momento pero hay que saber que esto es
concierne a los adultos los niños
menores de 12 a 17 años pueden ingresar
sin problemas aunque no sean vacunados
Javier su opinión sobre este tema sobre
esta decisión del gobierno francés que
difiere de algunos países europeos vemos
por ejemplo el caso de Hungría que ellos
incluso han comprado lotes de la vacuna
sputnik B para inocularla a su
ciudadanos sin que esta cuenta con la
aprobación de la Ema la Unión Europea ha
sido Clara también es decir que los
países pueden dictaminar la legislación
que ellos quieran
los países son soberanos de tomar las
determinaciones que ellos deseen no sin
embargo ya estamos viendo un problema de
inequidad en la en el acceso a vacuna a
nivel mundial y ahora Estamos viendo
otro problema de inequidad agravada
porque solamente se están autorizando o
permitiendo cuatro vacunas que aprueba
la la agencia de medicinas de Europa
yo estoy Completamente de acuerdo con la
Organización Mundial de la Salud en que
a nivel mundial las vacunas autorizadas
por la OMS son las que deberían ser
aceptadas por todos los países por igual
y de hecho si uno por ejemplo revisa
la prevención de enfermedad grave de
hospitalización de muerte de las vacunas
inactivadas sinovac sinofar y de la
vacuna rusa sputnik V que se han
publicado por chile por Argentina por
Uruguay por Brasil
los resultados realmente son muy
similares en cuanto a la prevención de
enfermedades graves no pueden variar un
poco en cuanto a la prevención de
infección leve Pero en cuanto a la
infección grave los resultados son
bastante similares
Nicolás vamos directamente a conocer
otro de los casos ya le presentábamos
algunos de los testimonios pero les
hablábamos de Nicolás que es colaborador
de France 24 lo decíamos él Recibió la
vacuna sinovac que es desarrollada en
China Nicolás cuéntenos su perspectiva
sobre este tema y cómo se siente usted
sobre esta decisión no poder entrar a su
país para hacer un procedimiento que
están exigiendo ahora que es poder
recibir ese pase sanitario que incluso
fue aprobado hace poco por las
autoridades para poder acceder a sitios
públicos
pues Santiago muchos franceses del
extranjero vivimos esta medida como como
algo discriminatorio porque en términos
generales
usted no elige la vacuna que le inoculan
cuando usted se acerca un punto de
vacunación a usted de ninguna manera le
presentan seis vacunas para que para que
elija lo otro que es bastante incómodo
es que
uno siente que gobierno francés Está
tratando a los franceses del extranjero
vacunados con sinovac y sputnik tal como
Trata a los anti vacunas o las personas
que no se quieren vacunar en el
territorio francés y yo creo que el
comportamiento de los dos grupos
poblacionales es totalmente diferente en
el primer caso francés del extranjero
vacunados con sinovaquia sputnik han
respetado las reglas de juego han ido a
vacunarse Y en el otro caso si tenemos
una una población que de pronto está
generando una dificultad pues con la
transmisión del virus
sí Philip le pregunto por qué se
politizó el tema de las vacunas
claramente los países están Armando
sus grupos la Unión Europea pues tiene
que tomar una decisión en común los 27
en algunos de los casos pero claramente
se formaron bandos que también vemos en
otras áreas de la geopolítica
internacional y las vacunas en una
pandemia de este nivel era necesario
tener que armarse otra vez otra vez
bandos entre los países Ay hay varios
primero uno puede regresar a Francia sin
ningún problema con cualquier vacuna
pero no entrando por Francia entrando
por España y después entra a Francia yo
conozco casos de gente de Brasil francés
que entraron a Francia pasando por
Holanda o pasando por otros países
Entonces si es posible para cualquier
francés Ingresar a Francia no
directamente Estamos de acuerdo segundo
al nivel de lo que están pidiendo en
este momento no es el Paz sanitario o si
no demostrar que uno tiene aire negativo
O sea que no es una obligación también
hacerse vacunar segundo la gente que
está manifestando frente al paz y hay
gente vacunados que no están de acuerdo
de ser fichados entonces hay diferentes
temas que entra yo hablé con unas
personas que están manifestando en París
para saber un poquito que pasaban no
solo estamos vacunados estamos en contra
de justamente Esther este este fichaje
del Paz sanitario entonces son
diferentes temas que se está abordando
ahí pero quiero decir que un francés que
quiere regresar a Francia puede pasando
por otro país sin ningún problema Claro
pero le estaba preguntando porque ese
politizó a nivel internacional este tema
porque vemos otra vez esas alianzas
internacionales y rechazando un producto
que viene de China un producto que viene
de Rusia que tienen demostrado
médicamente y por la comunidad
científica que funciona para combatir el
Kobe 19 bueno primero no estas mismas
cepas no está hecho de la misma manera y
lo están estudiando y yo sé que están
tardando para estudiar justamente
como dices es un tema político
geopolítico frente a Rusia frente a
China obviamente pero lo que vemos es
que seguro que al nivel de que cuando ya
han hecho todos los test lo van a
autorizar el problema es que en este
momento está tardando y ahí es
geopolítico Es por eso que está tardando
para hacer todos ustedes la agencia
Europea y no estamos hablando de Francia
estamos hablando la agencia Europea de
medicamentos lo que es más grave aquí al
nivel geopolítico es que vemos Que
África no está vacunado es decir que
estamos hablando de menos de un por
ciento de la población entonces ahí si
el problema de acceso a las vacunas lo
vimos con el presidente acaba de
entregar de 100 millones de euros Para
apoyar justamente al Líbano en este
momento en el reportaje que mostrado
anteriormente pero también va a apoyar
con vacunas porque hay una desigualdad
en acceso a las vacunas de los países
Javier sus impresiones en torno al
desempeño usted que es infectólogo le
hago una pregunta un poco más de de su
área sobre el desempeño que tienen las
diferentes vacunas porque la vacuna sino
han sido de pronto rechazadas por países
de occidente Estados Unidos Canadá la
Unión Europea Qué diferencias hay entre
estas vacunas están abismal el desempeño
de la vacuna como para considerar las
que no funcionan o que no pueden ser
tomadas en consideración
no Quizás lo que sucede es que Los
criterios o los requisitos que exigen
las agencias regulatorias ya llámese Efe
de agua son bien estandarizadas para
países europeos y para Estados Unidos no
Mientras que los países asiáticos de
Rusia ellos se ciñen con sus propias
agencias reguladores y tienen otro tipo
de requisitos no Entonces a veces es
complicado que una agencia reguladora
vaya a inspeccionar a las plantas de
producción en países en donde
normalmente no no se les está permitido
y ellos hacen su propia regulación no
así que definitivamente que hay una hay
un tema político involucrado sin embargo
cuando uno ve los resultados de los
estudios de la sputnik son muy similares
a astracénicas Johnson y Johnson moderna
y cuando veo los resultados de sinovac
sinofar en términos de prevención de
enfermedad grave también son muy
similares
Así que realmente yo creo que el
gobierno francés Debería ser una como
bien señaló antes de no solamente tener
vacunas
y Ojalá que pudieran aceptar vacunas
aprobadas probablemente sino por ejemplo
tener una pcr negativa o una persona que
haya sufrido Coby ya es una persona que
a lo mejor por 6 a 9 meses Está también
protegida contra una reinserción así que
esa esa flexibilidad Debería Debería
implementarse no lo otro que yo creo que
es importante es que es la primera vez
que se exige una marca o una procedencia
geográfica para discriminar con respecto
a una vacuna Porque por ejemplo en
sarampión en Fiebre amarilla en otras
infecciones no se pide que quien produce
la vacuna que marca es y y se está
haciendo ahora con con el covid no creo
que sea realmente muy Sensato no
claro entendible ese punto de vista
Javier ají en Ciudad de Panamá Nicolás
quiero seguir profundizando en su caso
ya lo decíamos en la introducción
ustedes ciudadano Colombo francés se
tiene ambas nacionalidades
Philip mencionaba el trabajo de las
embajadas usted tuvo contacto con la
bajada francesa en Bogotá sobre el tema
de las vacunas recibió algún tipo de
información o usted se acercó a la
embajada o al consulado para preguntar
sobre la posibilidad de recibir algún
tipo de vacuna por parte del gobierno
francesa y en territorio colombiano yo
recibí un mensaje el como muchos otros
franceses del extranjero aquí en
Colombia el pasado 22 de Julio si mal no
recuerdo donde anunciaban una campaña de
vacunación con janssen entre primero y
el 15 de agosto para los 18:55 años yo
aplaudo Por supuesto esta medida Pero no
puedo dejar de pensar que es un poco
tardía también Creo que esto se ha
podido hacer un poco antes sobre el tema
de las embajadas Quiero comentarle algo
de lo que he tenido conocimiento
hay testimonios de franceses en el
extranjero radicados por ejemplo en
cambodia en Asia que han dicho que la
misma embajada francesa le recomendó
abro comillas vacunarse con la solución
local en tiendas sinovac y así lo
hicieron y ahora el gobierno francés
saca la medida del pase sanitario y les
dice básicamente que no reconoce sinovac
yo creo que ahí eso demuestran alguna
medida Pues que el manejo no ha sido
óptimo y Y sí se vive como algo un poco
discriminatorio
que reclamo Entonces le asuste al
gobierno francés que he pedido le hace
usted a las autoridades sanitarias de
ese país europeo no solo yo sino muchos
otros franceses radicados en el
extranjero yo creo que
quienes hemos sido vacunados con sinovac
o sputnik
deberíamos recibir el pase sanitario
como Quienes se vacunaron con pfizer
moderna janssen y astrazeneca no
elegimos la vacuna respetamos las reglas
nos acercamos a los puntos de vacunación
y fuimos vacunados como como debe
hacerse claro adelante Usted tiene algo
para notar sobre este tema
teníamos que cumplir con el reglamento
colombiano llevo las vacunas antes el
segundo yo conozco muchos colombianos
que fueron al turismo y vacunas porque
sabían que esas vacunas no iban a ser
autorizadas en muchos países entonces
tenía los medios y se fueron a Estados
Unidos a vacunarse porque aquí les
ofrecían y no querían nacido Entonces
eso sí fue probético pero hacía meses
que sabíamos que eso iba a tardar eso no
nos vamos de sorpresa realmente claro
por eso eso hay que tener en cuenta que
no todos los ciudadanos franceses Por
más que estén viviendo en el exterior
tiene la posibilidad de viajar a Estados
Unidos a vacunarse en el caso que vivan
digamos en la región de América Latina
donde se pueden acceder a vuelos de
buenos precios para ir a Estados Unidos
no todos tienen la posibilidad de
hacerlo Philip continu usted para
preguntarle el tema de la garantía de
derechos a los ciudadanos franceses por
fuera aquí nos está violando un poco no
se está dejando unas garantías de lado
con tal de mantener esta posición
política esta decisión o como ustedes lo
quieran llamar y se está dejando de lado
a los ciudadanos franceses por fuera
porque las embajadas también sobre el
tema se han quedado con las manos
lavadas
durante las últimas elecciones
consulares donde hubo justamente muy
pocos votantes Porque muchos franceses
del exterior piensan que están dejados
por las embajadas y dejado por Francia
Eso sí es una es una situación que hemos
vivido y a muchos testimonios la gente
en este momento está desvinculado con de
los servicios diplomáticos
Javier lo mencionábamos también a lo
largo de esta discusión el pasaporte
sanitario que impuesto Francia para que
las personas puedan acceder a diferentes
sitios públicos también como una
exigencia para los trabajadores de la
salud que tienen que estar vacunados
para poder continuar con sus trabajos
una medida recientemente aprobada en
allí en Francia estos pasaportes
sanitarios Qué opinión merece por parte
suya son válidos ayudan a intensificar
la vacunación a mitigar el impacto de la
pandemia como lo vio usted
bueno son dos temas distintos no el
primer tema que estábamos debatiendo y
estoy de acuerdo Completamente de
acuerdo con Nicolás es que con esta
medida de solamente aceptar cuatro
vacunas
le estamos dando gasolina a los anti
vacunas para que enciendan el debate no
y es muy distinto un antivacuna a una
persona que voluntariamente ha ido a
vacunarse como sputnite con sinovac de
forma sensata Y de forma responsable no
solamente para protegerse a él sino para
protegerlas todo su entorno no así que
ahí hay una discriminación evidente no
con el tema de estrategias para
estimular la vacunación a ellos sí
realmente estoy de acuerdo por ejemplo
en instituciones de salud yo creo que
los médicos deben por obligación y las
enfermeras y todo el personal de salud
estar vacunados porque no solamente
protegen ellos si no se protegen a todos
los pacientes que tienen que atender y
además el personal de salud debe dar un
ejemplo al resto de la de la sociedad no
y es una forma de estimular pues la la
aceptación de la vacuna en otras partes
no Y también yo creo que también las
estrategias de eventos musicales eventos
deportivos discotecas bares restaurantes
en proteger a sus clientes y en exigir
que que la que lo que vayan ahí estén
vacunados yo creo es una medida sana y
que estimula o debe estimular la
vacunación de y alcanzar la inmunidad de
rebaño que es lo que Todos queremos para
salir de una vez por todas de la
pandemia no Claro que sí Javier usted
que conoce bien los las diferentes
agencias sientes reguladores de los
diferentes países o por lo menos tiene
claro alguno de los de los estándares
que tienen la Ema que es el ente
regulador de salud allí en la Unión
Europea Qué tipo de estándares tiene
para dejar de lado a las vacunas rusas y
la vacuna china son estándares y
rigurosos muy difíciles que tal vez el
procedimiento con el que fue
desarrollada este tipo de vacunas no es
el más acertado porque le hago la
pregunta porque inicialmente hubo muchas
críticas a la vacuna sput porque fue
desarrollada mucho más rápido que la de
pfizer o que la misma vacuna sinovac de
hecho fue la primera vacuna que salió al
mercado y que comenzó a hacer inoculada
en humanos
Yo estoy de acuerdo en que haya
regulación no porque los productos que
se dan
a las personas productos sanitarios
tienen que tener alta calidad no Y la
Ema tanto la Ema como la fda y como
algunas otras agencias reguladoras por
ejemplo la de Canadá la de Australia son
agencias bien rigurosas en que no
solamente
exigen todo un dossier de documentación
tanto de las los estudios que se han
hecho in vitro estudios en animales
estudios en seres humanos en las
diferentes fases sino que también exigen
certificados de calidad de producción de
manufactura y también muchas de estas
agencias exigen asistir o inspeccionar
las plantas de producción en los
diferentes países y ahí sí hay un
escollo importante no porque
los rusos y los chinos evidentemente
pues no están muy de acuerdo con que
entes externos vayan a inspeccionar a
sus plantas no Entonces ese quizás sea
el
el obstáculo más importante para para
este tipo de vacunas
le preguntó retomó el tema de las
garantías para los ciudadanos fuera del
territorio francés Qué tipo de garantías
se les puede dar Qué puede hacer el
gobierno francés por ellos garantizarles
una tercera dosis garantizarle el envío
de vacunas de las de las farmacéuticas
que ellos tienen aprobadas que puede
hacer el gobierno francés por ellos
bueno lo que está haciendo en este
momento
las embajadas ya están vacunando a
partir de 18 años Estamos esperando que
dentro de poco pueden vacunar a los
niños entonces que haya más vacunas más
centro de vacunación para los franceses
porque no hay que olvidar que un país
como Colombia más o menos el 30% de los
franceses solo Franco colombianos tiene
más de 70 años o sea que ya son adultos
mayores que justamente hay que proteger
porque ahora Estamos hablando también de
la tercera dosis en Francia ya empezaba
abordar y en Alemania también y Comparto
el tema yo creo que también el tema de
Francia es que si no se puede
tradicional desde la agencia Europea de
medicamentos no lo pueden permitir es
decir que hay hay un Excel que cumplir
si no cumplen ese Excel es por eso que
no pasa entonces no solamente está la
parte de geopolítica al nivel del apoyo
ellos vamos a tener nuevos Embajadores
Espero que van a continuar con este
trabajo y a que justamente ver que cómo
nos va a ir con este paso sanitario Qué
información está recopilando estamos muy
alertas también con esto es decir que
los que estamos en pro de las vacunas
Hay unos que estamos mirando justamente
este pasaditario a qué va a servir y si
es la primera fase justamente de una una
Cruzada como llamamos aquí rápidamente
Philip este pase sanitario puede ser
emitido por las representaciones
diplomáticas francesas en el mundo o
esto solamente para las personas que
están en territorios franceses tanto
territorio continental como de ultramar
es una aplicación que nos dice con quién
nos encontramos A qué distancia estamos
Yo tuve la oportunidad de utilizarlo es
decir que si nos encontramos si en
frente a algo que ya fue contaminado
Entonces nos llama Entonces es un
control total de nuestros movimientos
también
Hablamos de la tercera dosis ya hay
países alrededor del mundo que la están
inoculando Israel es uno de ellos
Alemania también ya anunció que va a
empezar a vacunar a las personas que
están en alto riesgo que son adultos
mayores van a empezar a recibir una
tercera dosis podrían los pacientes o
ciudadanos franceses recibir una tercera
dosis de otra de las vacunas diferente a
la china o a la rusa para poder regresar
a su país esto es medicamente se puede
hacer
Bueno médicamente se puede hacer
mientras exista el estudio que lo avale
No porque no se puede especular con la
combinación de vacunas sino hay un
estudio una investigación sólida
rigurosa científica que avale de la
combinación No por ahora la única
combinación es que han sido más o menos
aceptadas son la vacuna de Johnson y
astracénica de primera dosis y la
segunda dosis de una vacuna rna
mensajero como pfizer y como moderna y
se están haciendo estudios en
Precisamente en Sudamérica en Asia
combinando las vacunas inactivadas con o
con otras vacunas no pero mientras no
haya la información científica es muy
poco probable que las agencias
reguladoras que son más rigurosas vayan
a aceptar ese tipo de combinaciones No Y
ahí vamos a tener también lógicamente
otra disyuntiva no lo otro Es que esto
de la pandemia y de la vacunación es
algo bien Dinámico No ahora ya hay
países muy pronto Israel Francia
Alemania pronto Estados Unidos de chile
que van a exigir una tercera dosis para
los adultos mayores de 65 70 años o para
los pacientes con cáncer
inmunosuprimidos etcétera no así que
eventualmente por ejemplo también a lo
mejor una directiva ser sin si una si un
francés que está en el exterior no se ha
puesto la tercera dosis y pertenece a
otro grupo de riesgo tampoco a lo mejor
se le va a permitir la entrada lo cual
va a Añadir más más dificultad al asunto
las dificultades y complemento la
información que usted decía Javier en
Argentina en donde han tenido problemas
para garantizar la segunda dosis de las
putnik B anunciaron que van a poner la
segunda dosis partiendo de la vacuna de
astracénica mientras reciben un lote de
sputnikbet para el resto de las personas
que ya tuvieron la primera dosis y
mientras ellos empiezan a fabricar
localmente la spot allí por laboratorios
argentinos Nicolás le pregunta usted se
pondría entonces una tercera dosis si es
llamado por la embajada francesa Qué
plan tiene usted que hacer está abierto
a las opciones tiene planeado ir a
Francia pronto
Cómo ve usted el futuro cercano en
cuanto a la vacunación suya
Bueno estoy aquí para hablar de mi
específicamente no esto toca a muchos
franceses que están en el en el
extranjero por supuesto si me
corresponde una tercera dosis de sinovar
me la pondré si me puedo poner una
tercera dosis de otra vacuna Por
supuesto que que que lo haré creo que
más allá de que haya un viaje o no
inminente esto es un asunto de
principios
creo que si el gobierno francés no
previo bien el tema de la vacunación con
los franceses del extranjero meses atrás
se transforma este tema del espacio
sanitario en algo discriminatorio y creo
que que hay que resolverlo hay que
resolverlo y no dejar en el Limbo A la
población claro no dejarlos en el Limbo
y tampoco tenerlos como ciudadanos de
segunda clase son ciudadanos franceses y
tienen que tener las mismas garantías
que los que están en el territorio
continental para el cierre philippe sus
conclusiones sobre este tema rápidamente
por favor
Bueno lo que vemos es que es una
obligación hacerse vacunar entonces todo
lo que se está haciendo en este favor Yo
no creo que diciendo que así no va con
la O con las muñecas se van a impedir
que la gente se vacunado que la que
están proponiendo en Francia y aquí en
América Latina son casi todas las
vacunas empezamos bueno Argentina que
puede ser problemático pero hay que
fomentar justamente esto graba con así
como digo si un francés quiere regresar
a Francia hay maneras legales de pasar
por otro país entonces puede ingresar
sin ningún problema pasando por España o
por o por los Países Bajos Eso sí
Javier su opinión para el cierre
no yo creo que como bien dice Nicolás
nosotros estamos viendo un problema de
falta de principio energético no en que
la inequidad y la discriminación están
siendo el pan de cada día a nivel
mundial no solamente en acceso a vacunas
de muchos países que todavía ni siquiera
ha empezado a poner sus primeras dosis y
algunos países industrializados que ya
están incluso hablando de poner una
tercera dos entonces a mí me parece que
es desafortunado lo que se está viviendo
en el mundo y ojalá los países
industrializados la Organización Mundial
de la Salud endereza en este tema por el
bien de toda la humanidad
pues ahí tienen ustedes las impresiones
es un tema de igualdad de garantías de
derechos de no discriminación y de
principios Serán las opiniones de
nuestros invitados a ustedes también
Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros en el debate siga con nosotros
[Música]